are now sitting down with samatha
Chandrika from Green Heron homecare at
the arc fusion radical Wellness Summit
thanks for joining us thank you thank
you having yeah this is a blast so let's
ask you about green hair and home care
so right now anyone that goes in to the
hospital has an operation whatever the
issue is that they're facing they end up
spending a lot of time afterward at the
hospital getting taken care of at the
hospital and that's very very expensive
expensive for the hospital and for the
Bears because they ultimately disappears
that pick up most of the cost and so the
cost reduction here for a hospital would
be to stabilize the an acute patient and
once the patient is stabilized it's more
of an observational type of stay and
that observation can be done at home but
there's a lot of technology that follows
the patient from the hospital to the
home and so it's intensive clinically
and technologically and that's what my
company intends to do so we save the
hospital costs but at the same time
there's an intense clinical
understanding that goes into stabilize
so maintain the patient you know yeah
and so like you said there needs to be
both a technology piece there because
there's so much technology that exists
yes in the hospital so there needs to be
some sort of technology in the home to
die into the hospital beds
yeah and advancement
bring the physician to the bedside yes
keep the patient stable because he's a
poster kilt these are acute patients but
essentially just think the place of care
is now the home instead of the hospital
bedside yeah transfer the bed out of the
hospital of the house the technology
piece has to follow on yes that's how it
is and how often does the nurse or the
physician come it it's typically twice
or thrice a day just as a nurse would
visit you at the hospital bedside but
there's a triaging process involved and
it's very senior ICU nurses are the ones
that decide how many the second wire
it's the same level of care and studies
have shown that the outcomes are similar
for home base and hospital care and with
the cost reduction so we hope to achieve
similar medical outcomes
the requisite number of visits and we
decided by the jacket notes so Green
Heron is the first technology connection
from the home to the hospital that's the
first step of the piece in the second
step of the piece is the training
training or rather there's a in the
Boston area specifically there's a good
supply of highly skilled ICU and
inpatient nurses and the cost cutting
pressures and hospitals have you know
kind of they've got laid off and they
retired early but they're still
available for the workforce and that's
what we wanted that mmm so if you're not
going to retrain a nurse the nurse is
already available the highly skilled
nurse but she wants to work part-time
because she has family commitments by
that time in life yeah and so we're
gonna tap into that there's a supply
exactly somebody like us to come along
and tap it yeah yeah the supplies people
that want to do part-time nursing
whereas ago and they're highly skilled
and there's what some of these hospitals
in the first place but because of
cost-cutting measures a lot of people
highly skilled people are without work
or they retire early so there are a lot
of forces in play
the economics of healthcare and you know
these highly skilled people getting laid
off and from the demand-pull side there
are a lot of patients who don't want to
stay in hospital so very long yeah oh
yes
and it was metropoliz like possible
travel is long for caregivers very long
term hospitals yeah that logisitics and
transportation forces play as well and
then obviously there's the clinical
technological integration that a company
like us provides but the market has to
be ready for it and we feel that this
the greater boston market is ready for
this kind of service yeah I totally
think that many people prefer to spend
the days when they're starting to
recover in the home yes rather than the
hospital and then if the nurse can visit
their home two three times they they can
also get that assurance if they know
that the technology is also connected to
the hospital so all of the data and
feedbacks going back to the electronic
health record as well yes yeah
and so how did you figure out how to
tackle the technology side of things I
have a background in health technology
and I've been my pieces of MIT wasn't
using the health IT and hospitals my
co-founder is a nurse
these data systems and so you know it's
it's a fusion it's always a synthesis
and you know just like San Francisco has
a wellspring of ideas and so the more
you talk
I don't understand what forces are
shaping up
mine so it's
I'm lucky to be here in Boston and like
you you do you so many people in the San
Francisco area and this Silicon Valley
after all the same forces yeah yeah you
so how what are the tools what are the
were the technology pieces in my home
that I would have that could communicate
with the hospital yes Alan I'm glad you
asked me that because this is something
that we discussed just prior as well
using a handheld phone linked to fitness
devices is consumer great technology and
though it's great it's convenient but to
convert that piece of hardware or
software to a 24 by 7 up time system is
a step up yeah so we're using those
step-up devices and step-up gateways to
be able to time we can collect the data
and transmit it reliably over to the
hospital example you won't want that if
there's a power outage or there's a
rainstorm that the patient monitoring at
the bedside to go out yeah and if the
patient becomes critical at that point
of time the doctor sitting in hospitals
cannot monitor him that's a really good
point so these are enterprise level
highly reliable systems and obviously
the cost factor is higher but it's it's
cheaper for the hospital to invest in
this technology then keep the patient at
the bedside and that's where the cost
economics comes out Oh interesting so
hot so you're actually going to sell the
technology of the hospitals and then
you're going to also provide them with
the database of all the purr of the
nurses as well that can then go to the
locations on-site it's something like
that ok yeah yeah ok ok so your first
client is hospitals then our first class
a hospital that taking care of the
patients for them we are the
intermediary
that is able to homecare Eric green hair
home Jerry bundling the clinical and the
technology together to be able to
provide a hospital the facility of
sending the patient's own money
interesting yeah so you've already done
this with six patients yes we have six
patients and you know that gives us
enough confidence to approach a hospital
yeah ask them for their overflow
patients and once you put the
relationship that's when they start
sending you the acute patients yeah so
it's always a gradual process exactly
yeah nice this is great to learn about I
think this is gonna be very important
for people to want to get home for
people to want to get further employed
for nurses your further for the hospital
decrease the cost for the hospital this
is very important work yes it's kind of
holistic just like your other
yeah thank you smart thanks for joining
us a teaching us about this thank you it
is my pleasure being it